so a lot of parents have had this
experience you send your kid off to
college you're proud Dylan got into Duke
we're so happy and then the kid comes
back and hates not only you but the
country and himself and the chances of
that child having a happy productive
personal life go to about zero that's
the fruit of liberal arts in this
country now
so it's a very common experience but one
mother decided to try and fix it she
sent her daughter to a town attend Mount
Holyoke University of Massachusetts
tuition over 50k a year
the child comes back totally programmed
like a cult member so the mom spends 300
bucks a day for a deep programmer to
undo the brainwashing and it worked
Annabelle Rockwell is the daughter she
graduated Mount Holyoke she's now the
development director of prageru she
joins us so Annabelle thank you so much
for coming on so deep program suggests
undoing unreasonable religious belief
did you feel like a like a cult member
after Mount Holyoke
Tucker thank you so much for having me
first I'm gonna say that I arrived at
Mount Holyoke bright-eyed and
bushy-tailed so excited to be there in
2011 and as soon as I got there I was
told that you know I should refer to
myself as a first year not a freshman
because we were a historically women's
college I was left a note in my mailbox
saying he may be a she she may be a he
don't assume anyone's gender and I
thought oh okay like that's new and then
the last thing was we had the moho chop
which was this ritualistic haircut that
people did in the first semester where
everyone would shave their head
sort of as an act of rebellion so to
answer your question yes I mean as time
went on and I studied history I became
completely brainwashed into believing
that I was oppressed by our toxic
patriarchal society and I left school I
was sad anxious intellectually starving
and by 2015 when I graduated I
completely estranged myself from my
family
yeah well that's that is Underneath It
All We joke about the lunacy and college
campuses but the real cost is not that
they'll vote Democrat the real cost is
that they won't love their parents
anymore and that's that's the most
upsetting part of it I think so how did
you get better
so in this Panic of me not communicating
with my mother she consulted a cult
specialist uh this person gave her
devastating statistics that most people
don't make it out but a glimmer of hope
that it tends to be young women who do
so she spoke to him and he made it very
clear to her do not affirm your
daughter's Newfound identity you know
her best she is your child don't affirm
yes so she was taught how to communicate
with me
now to actually be deprogrammed I had to
humble myself a couple things I
reconnected with my family I moved home
I asked for forgiveness I admitted I was
wrong secondly I made a lifestyle change
I stopped drinking I started to believe
in God again and lastly I had to unlearn
my four years of wokism by watching
five-minute prageru videos on online for
free
amazing it is a cult its aim is to
separate you from the people who love
you most and I just I I'm so impressed
and have such respect for your mother
for taking it as seriously as it
deserves to be taken in for you for
getting out of it Annabelle Rockwell of
prageru thank you so much for coming on
thank you so much for having me